the u.s congress has certified joe biden
as the winner of november's presidential
election
after a day of chaos and violence in
washington
the session was forced into emergency
recess when a violent mob
of president trump supporters forced
their way into the capitol building
to try and stop lawmakers from
certifying the vote congress reconvened
later for proceedings that went
late into the night and saw several
republican lawmakers
abandoning their planned objections to
the election results
the unprecedented scenes unfolded after
trump had urged his supporters to rally
at the capitol as lawmakers debated the
results
after biden's victory was certified
trump released
the following statement he said even
though i totally disagree with the
outcome of the election and the facts
bear me out nevertheless there will be
an orderly transition on january 20th
he then added i have always said we
would continue our fight to ensure that
only legal votes were counted while this
represents the end of the greatest
first term in presidential history it is
only the beginning of our fight to make
america great again
let's go to washington for the latest
dw's oliver salad is standing by for us
there hi oliver
if we look at where things stand right
now certification has been completed in
congress
we have seen this statement at least on
paper from president trump
saying that there will be an orderly
transition does that mean that this is
now
over
certainly not sumi those are the kind of
mixed messages we've been getting from
president trump throughout his
presidency
and you read it out yourself he in his
speech in contrast to what he said in
his written statement said
this is not the end this is just the
beginning and he also
let's be very clear did not distance
himself from the protest that cost
four lives at this point by the way and
he said we love you you are special
people so that simply shows that donald
trump is determined to go
on he will certainly not let go as
easily in the next two weeks
will be crucial for american democracy
of course
um after all a trump pism is not going
to disappear
so quickly and there is a big danger for
joe biden and his presidency that there
will be some kind of right-wing
terrorism
uh resulting out of that that will
overshadow uh his presidency
oliver a lot of questions being asked
today about whether president trump will
face consequences for
what happened what's your take on this
well there are some republicans who are
already breaking loose uh
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
vice president mike pence also one of
his closest allies
south carolina senator lindsey graham
openly criticized him
in that late night session in senate
yesterday
and there are some reports that
preliminary talks underway are underway
of
several cabinet members and they're
discussing of they're discussing
invoking
the 25th amendment of the constitution
that is a an amendment that allows to
remove
the president from office now a majority
of cabinet
would then have to declare the inability
of donald trump to discharge his duties
and should that happen vice president
mike pence would become president for
the remainder of the time because no
matter what happens and if that happens
in the end
on january 20th is the inauguration
and that means that joe biden from that
day will be the new president of the
united states
oliver how concerned are people there in
washington about the state of american
democracy right now whether institutions
here really have been damaged
yeah it is certainly a dark day in
american history and
as you said the damage to the to the
institutions
is enormous also if you consider the
misuse
of power of the that the president
did there um by inciting his supporters
there's certainly a big damage also done
to the office
of the president the reputation of
american democracy
consider uh that the us has always been
uh
trying to export democracy leading by
example so all of that credibility is
certainly
lost and uh that will cast a big shadow
over the joe biden presidency will be a
big challenge also for him
in the coming four years and a damage
that will be certainly felt throughout
the next years
and oliver just quickly are there
concerns that we could see more
violence more unrest in the days to come
absolutely and it's also important to
point out that this is not the first
time that a protesters storm a
a capital similar scenes we've seen uh
earlier this year in michigan
um when a protester stormed the the
state's uh
state house there protesting the
governor's
covet lockdown there we also filmed with
armed militias here at dw this summer
they were training and were pretty
open about the fact that they were ready
to take to the guns
and and serious uh serious threats uh
certainly
for for american democracy in the weeks
to come
dw's oliver sallett reporting for us
from washington good to talk to you
you